welcome back to CBS mornings it's time
to bring you some of the stories that we
call Talk of the table why because it's
a table and we be we be talking we'd be
talking this morning we're joined by
comedian Chelsea Handler she'd be
talking too no we know Chelsea from her
very popular late night show it was
called what was it called Chelsea oh
Chelsea Lately Chelsea Lately it ran for
seven years thank you very much and now
get this she's guest hosting the Daily
Show all this week we're on that just a
moment but first let's get right to talk
of the table you're in Pole Position
Dave all right here we go welcome by the
way thank you to have you here so my
talk at the table is one of the sweetest
moments from last night's Grammys it was
my favorite moment at the end so the
show included a round table with
superfanes representing every nominee
for album of the Year discussing why
they think their favorite should win and
there was this one woman a 78 year old
lady from Canada who was a ginormous
Harry Styles fan she kept reading people
the right act about why Harry would win
and sure enough at the end Trevor Noah
was on the stage she's got the envelope
he's about ready to read it and he turns
and I think uh oh the show's going off
the rails here and he runs to that lady
I like to let her do this watch I like
that too and the Grammy goes to
you can read it
Harry Styles
[Laughter]
there's 78 years old her name is Rina
she is from Ontario Canada not only did
she get to say his name once she got it
out they let her give him his Grammy yes
but look what he did when he went up
there yeah when he went up there to get
it he gave her a big and prolonged hug
which I just thought would probably mean
the world to her but that really is who
he is
and he does love older women yeah ah he
has a history of that I mean who doesn't
[Laughter]
all right so uh sticking with the
Grammys though my talk to the table is
the Grammy's big celebration of 50 years
of hip-hop check it out
[Music]
the rappers can't stand it but give us
respect
what a moment it was hip hop Legends LL
Cool J Method Man Queen Latifah Run DMC
and many many more they jammed on the
Grammy stage last night and then for the
first time in nine years Jay-Z performed
at the Grammys the 24-time winner 24
times wow joined DJ Khaled to perform a
nearly five minute verse of the song God
did to close out the show and I can't go
without mentioning a special award for
Dr Dre last night the legendary rapper
and producer was given the newly renamed
first ever Dr Dre Global impact award
Force decades in music and contributions
to the culture just a great moment yes I
thought so too I love that he gets the
first ever Dr Dre award and he gets it
and accepts it he's also awesome my talk
at the table is a look inside behind the
scenes Clive Davis's legendary iconic
pre-grammy Gala at the Beverly Hilton
Hotel was Saturday night so this
star-studded event returned for the
first time in three years there's Maron
Morris was there I mean Sheryl Crow
performed there of course is Clive who
was introduced by Kevin Costner Jennifer
Hudson did a tribute to Whitney Houston
this was the 10th anniversary of her
death by the way so she did a knockout
performance I had a lovely neighbor to
sing with as we watched The One and Only
Frankie Valli perform I know I love this
song too
pictures
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody was on their feet for that it
sounded really loud on my iPhone
the sound was really great on my iPhone
it sounds a little muffled there but
everybody was on their feet nobody knew
Frankie Valli was in the room he's 85
years old and everybody young old
everybody seems to know this song
what'd you think of the Grammys well
first of all dude haven't you been
taking singing lessons
you heard it you heard it I still need
some work to do but at least I sing with
gusto I never said I was good but I was
saying I love it I love that you're
taking singing lessons I need to take
some dancing lessons is what I need to
do I don't have a lot of Rhythm did you
watch the Grammy's last night I did
watch them yes in preparation to come on
this show so I love them I mean there
were so many beautiful performances it's
just so nice to see people win Awards
it's like the Olympics you're just so
happy it doesn't matter who wins I know
yeah so true and I also I have to say
this he hadn't had the party in a while
because of covet of course but everybody
was so glad just to be out to be there
and be surrounded human beings and there
was something for every single musical
taste it was great the biggest part of
the year it really is it's so much fun
Chelsea but we got to talk to you about
your show because you're guest hosting
tonight and backstage Chelsea told me
I'm pumped I'm psyched I'm ready yes I'm
really excited I'm guessing The Daily
Show all week and I couldn't be more
pumped up I'm into it and uh I guess
hosted for Jimmy Kimmel over the summer
a while ago and I just it re kind of
invigorated my desire to do that again
so I'm really excited to get in there we
have Rafael Warnock on tonight that's an
interesting choice for a first guest you
chose him why uh well because I just
admire him so much because he had such a
tight race in Georgia this year and
because he's one of the stars of the
democratic party you think you'll ask
him anything about Herschel Walker I
think I might have to now I think I
might have to get in there a little
something about that I find Herschel
Walker to be very upsetting you know
that the fact that that was a tight race
and that he was even a candidate so I
think we're gonna have to touch on it
but you you know a thing or two about
doing late night TV and there are no
women on late night TV why do you think
that is and why do you think that you
could change that Chelsea Handler a lot
of people pull in for you uh well oh
well thank you I mean I have a pretty
good track record of doing it uh you
know and I do love it and I'm in the
mood to work and I think when you're in
the mood to work and you have the right
attitude that you uh always deliver the
goods there's been a lot that's happened
since your show ended right we had the
metoo movement we've had a global
pandemic the world is different as you
sit at the table tonight are you in any
way different as a comedian yes I think
we've all kind of had to evolve and I
and and thankfully so you know I'm not
really interested in all these people
talking about the parameters of cancel
culture and how limiting that is it's
not that limiting all they're asking you
to do is not be sexist or racist that's
not a tall order no so when people
complain about that I feel very I have a
very strong desire to put a show
together and demonstrate for people that
it's not that hard to accomplish you
know so I'm very eager to get back into
the late night scene Yeah you mentioned
cancel culture
um and you say that you're not afraid of
being canceled is that the reason why
because of the parameters in which
people are canceled you're like I'm not
I'm not well I'm not an idiot so I'm not
doing anything to be canceled you know
I'm smart enough to understand the pulse
of what's happening right and to change
your you know behavior and and have your
you know have your jokes not Target
anybody not to be discriminatory that's
not difficult right that's actually you
know challenging every comedian to be a
little bit more clever and I welcome
that challenge I like when you said you
know I'm not an idiot and it's not hard
to do it really isn't hard not to be
racist not to be sexist you've gone on
records saying you no longer want to
make fun of celebrities what do you mean
well some of them deserve it you know
what I mean it's like Elon Musk I don't
have a problem with making fun of or you
know some of those other people out
there that are just demonstrating bad
behavior but not these young girls that
are innocent you know on my old show we
would make fun of Britney Spears and
Lindsay Lohan and you could just see the
damage that that all did you know as a
society we all just piled onto these
girls and they're kind and they're
innocent you know so that's not
necessary
um I think you know the people that are
larger targets are the people that are
kind of taking advantage of of
everything of the world and not putting
out yeah yeah and you're going on the
road I got a new comedy your new comedy
I don't know if we can say it the witch
you're calling it The Rich rhymes with
it's a big little yeah and rhymes with
which oh yeah
yes yes yes I'm going on the road I just
released a new special on Netflix called
Revolution and to follow that up I'm
doing another tour about all the stories
of me when I was a little girl because
you're referring to yourselves I am the
little big witch yes yes I've been that
way since I was born you guys it's not a
new condition I was born with it The
Daily Show is a guest host do you want
the job permanently uh we'll see how
this week goes and you know what the
chemistry I'm going to take that as a
yes
there are people up for that job I'm
sure that have been there so we'll
discuss that you know when the time is
right I don't want to be obnoxious yeah
but but Chelsea that would mean you
might have to move to New York from L.A
how would you feel about it well you
know I'm originally from Nueva Jersey
Girls
if I'm wrong you like Gail and I love
Los Angeles right you like Southern
College I do love Los Angeles but you
know I go to bed at eight o'clock in L.A
there's not a lot going on I wouldn't be
opposed to moving to New York City I've
never lived in New York in my whole life
you haven't no and I I you know I I'm
open to it for sure there's a lot of
action here I mean it's almost a little
dangerous for me because I have a
personality where if you get me out I'll
stay out so they call it the city that
never also I hear you're in the dating
Market again ain't that fun yeah it's
hard out here
you know what Nate said to me once
Chelsea this is good he said Gail don't
worry your man's coming soon it's like a
movie trailer coming soon
I actually thought that was her cover of
2025. coming soon that's good I actually
thought that was a good line Chelsea
congratulations cheering you on good
luck tonight good luck all week good
luck all week thank you for coming and
playing with us you can catch Chelsea
guest hosting the Daily Show tonight on
Comedy Central